sure hi I'm David agus I'm a professor
of medicine and engineering at the
University of Southern California and
author of the new book the end of
illness so I wanted to answer a dabas
question from Elaine welcher's who said
from facebook please tell us what you
care about what future direction you
seek and how you will contribute to
improving the state of the world so I'm
a cancer doctor I fight disease every
day and one of the things I quickly
realizes i'm not good at treating
advanced cancer so i want to prevent
disease so the passion now is not to
have to look at somebody in the eye and
say I'm out of drugs to treat you I want
to prevent cancers and we have simple
measures to do it ranging from behavior
in lifestyle to sometimes some pills
like an aspirin or a statin and even in
countries what I learned here downloads
like sub-saharan Africa when that
Minister of Health Nigeria said to me 24
more people died in my country of cancer
than HIV tuberculosis malaria combined
and half of them are cervical cancers of
which we have a vaccine so we need to
push on the preventive model and my job
over the next several decades to push
hard as I can governments and
individuals to change those behaviors
make sure you look in the camera off
early